[Music]
lady why am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question um well actually
not just one I have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip you need
help with that no no I got it
I know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key but we get quite Roger that
[Music]
change of plans Jessie but Bo Rex potato
hey watch it buddy
oh let's go save a spork do I need to be
worried
my guys are veteran so hang in there
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man oh
yeah posing yeah hold on one more oh
yeah I've known that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside so
much body needs for kids Oh Sheriff
would you always come in to the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
do for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
he's being kept how do we get that key
what about the old plush rush there you
go well we're not doing that trying to
get money you the trouble no of course
not you could have been no no no guys
listen Bonnie had a great day in class
and we're going on a road trip road trip
did something really weird happened
Bonnie made a friend in class oh no no
no she literally made a new friend
[Music]
you're kidding me he said that to your
face to my face and then what happens
I'll get real close right I'm like I
don't care which Cabbage Patch
you're from Oh give me back my
viewmaster before I knock the dimples
off your face you are I don't care bear
you see the new movie trailer for what
you ain't see it see what what is it
ducky but they're making another Toy
Story movie I thought those movies were
gone dog they made three movies did make
three movies this is number four toy
stories - yay what about Buzz Lightyear
stuff I am Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger
what is like to infinity and your mom
that's not right you sure no that's not
right I'm pretty sure that's it immunity
hey guys you got it all wrong it's to
infinity and beyond
okay class crafts time
[Music]
we got this kindergarten saying under
control I can't believe talking to a
spork everyone Bonnie made a friend in
class no no she literally made a new
friend I want you to meet four key
chutes and ladders
Rita gee everyone Bonnie made a friend
in class oh she's already making friends
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to meet porky he's a spool yes
yeah I know
porky is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to him woody we
have a situation I am NOT a toy I was
paper soup salad maybe chili and then
the trash but we gotta get porky a
bourbon
why am i alive you're Bonnie's toy you
are going to help create happy memories
that will last for the rest of her life
huh come on bow bow hi my name is Gabby
Gabby we can't stay yes you can
boy what are you doing here
no time to explain come with me we need
to get back to our kids Oh Sheriff Woody
always come in to the rescue Bonnie
needs 40 woody who needs a kid's room
when you can have all of this Wow
woody are we going to Bonnie we have to
find the only two but what would he do
jump out of a moving vehicle let's go
hey you gotta go you gotta go
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could
open your eyes woody there's plenty of
kids out there sometimes change can
because you can't teach this old toy new
tricks you'd be surprised
Bonnie we're going home
on my way
kids lose their toys everyday I was made
to help a child I remember it being this
hard wait somebody's whispering in your
ear
you've got friends wow this place is
amazing
why's a buzz gonna meet us here he must
be held up somewhere hey up here Astro
Boy if you think you can take our top
prize spot your room
dead wrong help me get out of here
[Music]
everyone we're going on a road trip
vacation
[Music]
let's do this come on
help me get out of here no not this one
is that how we look are you kidding it's
a commercial it's not real I can't jump
that well actually not just one I have
all of them I have all the questions
kibou lady ji
[Music]
the angel
castle
[Music]
and everywhere
I put the tie
but now
only blockers
[Music]
everyone so
things I would
good clothes
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
I really don't know
[Music]
I don't belong here
[Music]
[Applause]
boy
hey somebody get down before coaching I
am
[Music]